the Italian city of Milan hosts the
world's number-one Furniture Fair some
2,500 designers and manufacturers are
presenting their new furniture designs
here
German design expert Matteo police comes
each year to view the newest design
ideas messages sites at Marriott's in
this trade fair has been the most
important annual forum for new products
for several decades this is where many
of today's classics were first unveiled
innovative materials timeless shapes or
new technologies Matteo Klee says these
are the prerequisites for future design
classics some companies produce new
versions of old classics
this year the Swiss furniture company
Vita is presenting a new variant of
French architect and designer Jean
Purvis classic table M it originated in
1956 or this object has established
itself as a classic that still produced
50 years later and we'll still be
produced in 50 years time but production
methods change taste changes so
manufacturers have to walk a tightrope
of keeping a successful design as close
to the original as possible while
ensuring it doesn't become a fossil
image next time for sylveon lastness
Swedish designers AnnaLynne clean and
Sophia lacquered fists of front design
are setting new standards with their
furniture designs
they made their names in 2005 with the
sketch chair they draw it in the air and
then use laser 3d printing technology to
manufacture it
we believe that as a designer you can
bring different technologies together
and find different areas that has never
met before and then
together you can make some things that
have been done before this year front
design are presenting an open display
case they took inspiration for its
wooden stick appearance from Mikado
today there are about a dozen designers
worldwide whose objects are immediately
recognizable and so have the potential
to become design classics Klee says
Constantin Richard and Stefan deeds are
among them
stephane Dietz is presenting the chair
which he calls that it's made of plywood
as was his tonot 404 chair from 2007 and
the Houdini furniture of 2008 the new
design is the first to be produced
industrially that saves money it's only
natural that you don't know until later
what will become a design classic
I'm not making any predictions but of
course this chair has one crucial
ingredient at least it is timeless it's
clearly an object you'll still enjoy
looking at in five or ten years time
that's characteristic of many classics
they don't try to seem original but are
reduced to the essentials it would see
us in doctors recently here only the
future will show whether or not the new
designs at this year's Milan Faire have
what it takes to become iconic
you